[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه
مما وراء الخبر في هجوم مباغت اوقع 30
قتيلا بين جنود النظام السوري تمكن
مقاتلوا الدوله الاسلاميه بحسب المرصد الس
لحقوق الانسان من السيطره على ثلاثه ابار
من حقل الشاعر النفطي الغازي الواقع في
محافظه حمص نتوقف اذا مع هذا الخبر لنناقش
في
محورين ما هي الدلالات الميدانيه
والسياسيه لسيطره مقاتلي الدوله الاسلاميه
على حقل
الشاعر اي حظوظ لنجاح الحمله الدوليه التي
تستهدف القضاء على التنظيم في ضوء المكاسب
التي التي حققها في حقل
[موسيقى]
الشاعر عديده هي المؤشرات التي توحي بان
الحرب المفتوحه بين تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه واعدائه ستكون طويله الامد
وباهظ الثمن اخر تلك المؤشرات جاءت من
محافظه حمص السوريه حيث تمكن مقاتل
التنظيم من بسط سيطرتهم على موقع الشاعر
النفطي الغازي عمليه خلفت
30 قتيلا بين جنود النظام السوري بحسب
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عمليه خلفت
ايضا اسئله حول ابعاد هذا التطور الميداني
وما يقف وراءها من رؤيه تنظيم الدوله
لكيفيه التعاطي مع الحمله الدوليه التي
تستهدف تحجيمه تمهيدا لشطب تماما من
المشهد ليست هي المره الاولى التي يسيطر
فيها قاتل تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه على حقل
الشاعر للغاز بريف حمص اقتحم مسلح التنظيم
بحسب المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان الحواجز
التي اقامتها قوات النظام السوري
والميليشيات المسانده لها في محيط الموقع
بعد اربعه ايام من المعارك الضاريه
السيطره على الموقع تفتح الطريق نحو مدينه
السلاميه الاستراتيجيه بريف حماه وبين ريف
حمص الشرقي وريف الرقه الجنوبي وهو خط
امداد مباشر للتنظيم قطع كافه خطوط النظام
السوري مزيدا من القوات لاستعاده الحقل
سريعا باعتبار اهميته الاستراتيجيه
والحاجه الماسه لانتاجه مع حلول فصل
الشتاء وفي وقت يضيق فيه الخناق على قوات
النظام في حقول اخرى لكن اسئله كثيره تحيط
بالعمليه نظرا لاهميه الموقع الاستراتيجي
ومن المفترض ان يكون جيد الحمايه من قبل
النظام خاصه انها ليست المحاوله الاولى
التي يستهدف فيها تنظيم الدوله الحقله منذ
يوليو الماضي يعتقد بعض المراقبين ان
التنظيم يستفيد كثيرا من جعل حقل الشاعر
ومحيطه منطقه توتر مستمر يقلق النظام
ويدفعه لحشد قواته ومليشياته في هذا
الموقع واداره حرب عصابات معها تخفف الضغط
عن المواقع الاخرى التي يسيطر عليها مسلحو
ويتعرض بعضها لقصف قوات التحالف الدولي
كما ان العمليه تشير بشكل او باخر الى
قدره التنظيم على التكيف مع ضغط مستهدفه
وهو الذي خبر طويلا مع ك الكر والفر وتضع
التحالف امام تحديات حقيقيه فبعد مضي اكثر
من شهر على عملياته يعترف قادته العسكريون
ولو بطريقه غير مباشره بعدم اكتمال ملامح
استراتيجيه مواجهه التنظيم كما تضيف سيطره
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه على حقل الشاعر
ورقه اخرى لصالح مؤيدي النظام السوري في
المجتمع الدولي واولهم روسيا التي ما فتئت
تدعو لتفعيل التشريعات المتعلقه بمبدا
سياده الدول على الموارد الطبيعيه
الموجوده على اراضيها وادانه المعتدين
عليها مهما كانت
تسمياتهم موضوع حلقتنا هذا اذا نناقشه مع
ضيفين من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي وايضا من لندن
الدكتور فواز جرجس استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
ومدير مركز الشرق الاوسط في جامعه لندن
نرحب بضيفي من بيروت ولندن اد معك العميد
الياس حنا يعني نريد ان نبدا في البدايه
بالشق الميداني او العسكري طبيعه هذا
الهجوم المباغت الذي اوقع 30 قتيلا في
صفوف الجنود السوريين يعني كيف نفهم ان
موقعا عالي التحصين يسقط هكذا بهذه
السهوله بيد مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وبهذه الكلفه البشريه العاليه
بالنسبه لجيش النظام السوري
عندما نقول مباغت انا اعتقد اليوم بناء
للنمط الذي اتبعته الدوله الاسلاميه او
داعش هناك عمليه تحضير مستمره تقوم على
مبدا الاستنزاف اذا صح التعبير وهذا الامر
اعتمد في العراق يعني اليوم هذا هذا النصر
السريع الخارق او الحرب الخاطفه التي حصلت
في العراق هناك عمليه تحضير اساسيه
للارضيه لانجاح هذا العمل العسكري
وبالتالي اليوم عندما نتحدث عن دير الزور
او عن ايه يعني الشاعر او حقل الشاعر هذا
يعني بعيد عن العاصمه ما يقارب ال 215 م
عن حلب 150 م فاذا هو في قلب سوريا ولكن
في قلب مركز الطاقه لسوريا لانه من هذه
المنطقه تنطلق كل الانابيب باتجاه البحر
والهب او النقطه الاساسيه هي حمص اليوم
الجيش السوري اصبح في امتداد الاقصى
ولثلاث سنوات دون توقف نتج ما يسمى بالتعب
الفتي بالنسبه لهذا الجيش وبالتالي ما حدث
في العراق رفع القدره العراق او ايران او
من من يعني من يريد المساعده لهذا النظام
وبالتالي اليوم بدانا نسمع انه النظام في
تعب ليس قادرا على الدخول في مواجهه خاصه
اذا كان هذا هذا الهدف بعيد 251 كمات فاذا
انا اعتقد انه في اعاده ترتيب الاولويات
لهذا النظام هذا عدا اهميه الحقل لداعش
بسبب قربه من العاصمه المفترضه ل التنظيم
وهي الرقه ا طيب دكتور فواز جرجس يعني هل
تعب الجيش السوري على مدار اربع
سنوات من القتال يبرر هكذا سقوط موقع
استراتيجي نفطيا موقع نفطي وغازي في يد
مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ما هي
التداعيات الاست استراتيجيه لسقوط هذا
الموقع بيد الدوله
الاسلاميه انا اعتقد ان ليس هناك من شيء
يبرر سقوط هذا الموقع الاستراتيجي المهم
للدوله السوريه هذه ليست المره الاولى
يعني التكلفه في المره الماضيه كانت مئات
الجنود والضباط من الجيش السوري القياده
السوريه كانت عليها ان تدرك تماما اهميه
هذا الموقع لانها استثمرت يعني الكثير من
قدرات الش الشحيحه في الفتره الاخيره ولكن
الحقيقه علينا ان لا نركز على موقع معين
ونتحدث عن هذا الموقع انا اعتقد ان تنظيم
تنظيم داعش تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه يعني
ما يزال يتمدد ليس فقط في سوريا ولكن ايضا
في العراق يحارب على عده جبهات متوازيه
يحارب على الجانب السوري التركي يحارب في
دير الزور يحارب في ادلب يحارب في تكريت
يحارب في الموصل في سنجار ويتمدد على
الرغم من الضربات الامريكيه يعني هذه
الضربات لم تعطي ثمارها حتى هذه اللحظه
النقطه الاولى يعني على الرغم من كل هذا
هذا التحالف وطبعا هو في البدايه النقطه
الثانيه ليس فقط الانجازات العسكريه لا
يمكن فصل الانجازات الميدانيه التي يحرزها
تنظيم داعش دون الحديث عن المهارات
السياسيه التي يبديها هذا التنظيم يعني ضد
اهم تحالف دولي يمكن منذ
نثمر هذه هذه المكاسب العسكريه كيف
يستثمرها سياسيا اذا لا اعطيك لا اعطيك
مثل صغير عن ذلك يعني تصوري معركه كوباني
يعني كوباني هي الحقيقه معركه رمزيه
للتنظيم ولكن التنظيم الحقيقه استثمر اكثر
من 500 مقاتل من اهم مقاتل من اجل ان يظهر
التناقضات في هذا هذا التحالف التناقضات
بين تركيا من جهه والولايات المتحده
التناقضات بين تركيا والاكراد من جهه اخرى
ايضا التناقضات بين التحالف والدوله
السوريه كيف يمكن لهذا التحالف يعني ان
وخاصه يعني على المدى القصير ان يعطي اي
ثمار بالنسبه لهذا التنظيم وهناك خلافات
جوهريه ليس فقط بين النظام السوري
والتحالف التي تقوده الولا المتحده ولكن
في داخل التحالف نفسه وايضا يعني بالنسبه
لحقل الشاعر الولايات المتحده قالتها وضو
وبوضوح انها لن تقوم باي ضربات جويه ضد
تنظيم داعش في المناطق القريبه من الدوله
السوريه لانها لا تريد ان تساعد النظام
السوري على تحقيق اي انجازات ضد المعارضه
السوريه ومن هنا قدره التنظيم الحقيه يعني
اخذ المبادره القدره الهجوميه المهاره
السياسيه كل هذه الاسباب الحقيقيه يعني
اعطت التنظيم زخما واظهرت بالفعل التحديات
الصعبه والخطيره التي يعاني منها التحالف
الدولي التي تقوده الولايات المتحده سيد
عميد الياس حنا يعني عندما يسيطر تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه على موقع مثل موقع
الشاعر م يعني ما حجم الفائده التي
يستفيدها يعني استراتيجيا عسكريا امنيا
واقتصاديا ايضا خطوط تمويل عفوا خطوط
امداد تفتح له مصادر تمويل ايضا من بيع
الغاز
والنفط
ا اليوم دير الزور بالكامل ليست تحت سيطره
التنظيم هذا تعتبر مركز ثقل اساسي او سنتر
اوف جرافيتي موجوده لانها تشكل عنصر طاقه
وهذا المصدر الطاقه هو مهم له لانه يستطيع
بيعه ومع انه اليوم بين بين الغاز وبين
النفط هناك فرق فرق كبير يعني هناك اصعب
بيع الغاز من منه بيع النفط لانه الغاز
يستلزم يعني بنى تحتيه مختلفه هلا اليوم
عندما يسيطر على هذه المنطقه انها
الامتداد يعني يعني بنظره بسيطه الى
الخارطه دير الزور الرقه وبالتالي كوباني
هذه المنطقه هي منطقه امتداد اساسي هلا
انا اعتقد اليوم ايضا انه هذا التنظيم وصل
الى الامتداد الاقصى الى اين سيذهب بعد
هذه المرحله كوباني تعتبر عقده بالنسبه
للتنظيم اليوم تستغل من كل الافرقاء لماذا
لانه اليوم يستثمر التنظيم في كوباني قوات
مهمه جدا ايضا اذا نظرنا الى هذه الخريطه
يتحكم التنظيم بتمويل الدوله السوريه او
النظام في سوريا ومنهم من يقول او حتى
الامريكيين انه النظام بوقت من الاوقات
يشتري الطاقه من من من من ه من تلك
المناطق او من داعش بطريقه غير مختلفه
خاصه انه الجزء الاساسي للطاقه في سوريا
موجود في هذه المنطقه منطقه دير الزورو
وما حولها وما اكتشف في البحر للنظام في
سوريا على الساحل السوري حتى الان يعني
بمساحه 2000 م و ونيف يعني لم يستثمر الان
ليست مشروع جاهز للاستعمال الاساسي هذا
يضع مزيد من الضغط وهذا يقول للنظام انت
فقدت العمق السوري الى الى غير رجعه يعني
نتحدث عن باديه الشام نتحدث عن المنطقه في
شرق سوريا والقريبه من الحدود
العراقيه هلا بالمعنى العسكري وبالمعنى
العملاني وبمعنى الكتي واستراتيجي داير
الزور بشكل عام هي اساسيه لانها امتداد
طبيعي
ل العاصمه المفترضه الرقا ويبدو وح يعني
ما هو موجود ان هذا الحقل هو جزء مهم لما
ينتج من غاز في في في قربه يعني معامل
تسييل هذا الغاز للقدره على نقله وبيعه
باماكن اخرى ولكن هل ستسمح الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان يستحصل النظام او
التنظيم على بيع طاقه الى جانب النفط
وبالتالي لا يمكن تشفيف مصادر الطا مصادر
المال لهذا التنظيم هذا امر اعتقد انه قد
نراه في المراحل القادمه اذا ناخذ فاصلا
قصيرا ثم نناقش بعد الفاصل الاستراتيجيه
التي يمكن لتنظيم الدوله ان يعتمدها
للتكيف مع الحمله الدوليه التي تستهدف
القضاء عليه لا تذهبوا
[موسيقى]
بعيدا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش الابعاد التي تعكسها سيطره
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه على موقع الشاعر
النفطي الاستراتيجي في سوريا نرحب بضيفنا
من جديد في بيروت وفي لندن دكتور فواز
جرجس يعني في الابعاد الاستراتيجيه ل لحدث
مثل هذا هل نستشف ان التنظيم اصبح له رؤيه
اوسع رؤيه جديده تتماشى مع متطلبات
المرحله المقبله ام اننا يمكن ان نقراه في
اطار هجوم
مباغت فقط على هذا الموقع انا انا اعتقد
انه السؤال الاهم ا يعني يا هل ترى هل
لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه لتنظيم داعش لديه
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه على المضى الطويل او
كل هذه يعني الانجازات اللي كانت في
كوباني او في دير الزور او في حقل الشاعر
او حتى في المناطق العراقيه هي الحقيقه
انجازات تكتيكيه لن تستثمر على المدى
الاستراتيجي لا اعطيك مثل زير ما اعني
بذلك القياده الامريكيه تقول انه انكم لا
تبالغون في اصدار الاحكام على هذا التحالف
هذا التحالف ما يزال في بداياته القياده
الامريكيه تقول عليكم ستراتيجيك بشنس
الصبر الاستراتيجي المعارك من سوف يكون له
اليد الطوله في السنه والسنتين القادمتين
هو الحقيقه الفريق الذي يمكن لديه الرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه النقطه الثالثه الولايات
المتحده تقول بانها تواجه معضله خطيره
للغايه اولا لا تريد ارسال قوات بريه الى
العراق وسوريا النقطه الثانيه القوات
البريه الموجوده غير كا للتعامل هجوميا مع
هذا التنظيم يعني الجيش العراقي في وضع
صعب للغايه القياده الامريكيه القناعه
هناك قناعه عن الجيش العراقي بحاجه الى
حوالي ست او تسع اشهر من اجل اخذ المبادره
الهجوميه من اجل حقيقه ليس فقط وقف تمدد
داعش واما لاسترداد المدن الرئيسيه الموصل
تكريد الفالوجه المثلث الثني ومن هنا
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه وحلفائها تقوم على
التالي يعني محاوله استنزاف التنظيم
محاوله معرفه يعني خبايا تنظيم
قدراته قيادته ادارته للمعارك ومعركه
كوباني ومعركه كباني الحقيقه اعطت
الولايات المتحده بعض يعني الرؤى عن تصرف
و يعني التنظيم وخاصه ادارته للمعركه
النقطه الرئيسيه هنا الحقيقه اعاده بناء
القوات المحليه العراقيه اعاده بناء
القوات الكرديه انشاء تحالف عشائري عربي
سني من اجل الانضمام الى هذا وكل هذا يعني
ماذا يعني هذا انها معركه طويله الامد
الحقيقه يعني نتيجه هذا طبعا وايضا معرفه
نتيجه هذا هذه المعركه غير محسوبه وايضا
وايضا يا هل ترى السؤالي انت سالتي انا لا
اعرف تماما بالفعل ولا احد يعلم ان
للتنظيم الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه للتكيف مع
هذه الاستراتيجيه الطويله المدى اذا عم
تساليني انا الرايي يعني انا بعرف
التنظيمات كلها من كتبت عده كتب عن هذه
التنظيمات رؤيتي انا وقراءتي المتواضعه
تقول بان التنظيم يتصرف بطريقه يعني
تكتيكيه وليست ط يعني طريقه استراتيجيه
لانه على المضى المنظور الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها سوف الحقيقه الحرب لم تبتدي بعد
يعني المعركه التصعيد يعني تصوري الولايات
المتحده قامت فقط بعشرات الطلعات في عشرات
الضربات الجويه في الاسبوعين الاخيرين هذه
لا تعتبر حرب بكل معنى الكلمه لان
الولايات المتحده تفتقر الى قوات بريه في
العراق وطبعا في سوريا الاولويه هي للعراق
وليس الى سوريا وليس الحقيقه هناك قوات
بريه في سوريا تمكن هذا التحالف من توجيه
ض ضربه قاده قاسمه الى التنظيم طيب هناك
اعتراف عميد الياس حنا هناك اعتراف من
قاده التحالف الدولي بانه الاستراتيجيه
المتبعه لم تكتمل بعد ماذ الذي ينقص
لمواجهه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه يعني ما
هي الثغرات الموجوده الان في استراتيجيه
التحالف الدولي لمواجهه هذا
التنظيم انا ساجيب عن هذا السؤال ولكن قبل
اريد ان اعلق على فكره بين التكتيكي وبين
الاستراتيجي اليوم دائما التكتيكي هو في
خدمه الاستراتيجيه الكبرى واليوم لكل فريق
من الافريقا استراتيجيته الخاصه وتكتيك
الخاص اليوم بالنسبه لتنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه هو لديه نظره استراتيجيه اساسيه
وهو حقق انتصارات تكتيه مهمه المشكله
اليوم لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه هو في
السياسه يعني اليوم عندما تعل تعلن
الخلافه وتقولين انا او لا احد او يا معي
يا ضدي هذا امر اساسي هذا يلغي البعد
السياسي يعني اليوم هذه الانجازات الكبيره
كيف سيتم الحديث عنها على طاوله مفاوضات
على طاوله سياسه كيف ستتعامل مع المفهوم
بالنظام العالمي اليوم النظام العالمي
اللي يعتمد على المنظمات الدوليه ولكن سوف
اترك هذا الموضوع لانه يعني من الخطا ان
نقول ان ان داعش ليس لديه استراتيجيه لديه
استراتيجيه ولكن الكومبات بيلتي التجانس
مع السياسه مفقوده ولكن لديه استراتيجيه
اليوم تحدثت عن الاستراتيجيه اليوم انا
اعتقد ان الامريكيين ينظرون الى مسرحين
اساسيين يعني ليس العراق اهم
سوريا وسوريا اهم العراق انا اعتقد انه في
نظره شامله بالمعنى الجراند استراتيجي او
الاستراتيجيه الكبرى واذا نذل الى مستوى
ادنى نقول ان هناك استراتيجيتين لكل مسرح
من المسارح مسرح العراق له ديناميه خاصه
والمسرح السوري له ديناميه مختلفه بالمسرح
العراقي هناك قدره على تعاون ايراني هناك
قدره على التعاون مع الدوله لانه الدوله
موجوده واخذت الامريكان اخذوا شرعيه معينه
من هذه الدوله ان ياتوا الى العراق هناك
1500 او 2000 بوتس اون جراوند اللي هن
الخبراء وهناك جزء اساسي بالعراق انه
قادرين على تامين الدعم الجوي على ان يكون
البوتس اوندر جراوند يلي حكي عنهم دكتور
جرجز موجودين ان كان بالجيش العراقي ولكن
هذا الامر يستلز اكثر من سته اشهر والبش
مرجا هم الجيش الثاني بونت ان جراوند وهلا
رايحين على سوريا الهدف الامريكي هو فصل
المسرحين المسرح السوري على المسرح
العراقي وهذا امر يستنزف فيه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه في كوباني ولكن المشكله على
المسرح السوري انه ما في تنظيم معين يمكن
اللجوء اليه اليوم بدانا نرى الحديث عن
الجيش السور الحر عن عن تنظيمات مختلفه
معتدله ولكن هذا الامر يستلزم اكثر من سنه
كي تتوضح هذه الامور اليوم قد يمكن دمج
المسرح السوري مع المطالب التركيه باقامه
منطقه عازله شرط ان تقوم هذه العاز زله
تحوي هذه المنطقه اللاجئين السوريين
القيادات السياسيه القيادات العسكريه و
ويكون التدريب فيها او قد تعلن مثلا حكومه
انتقاليه ولكن هذا الامر يتطلب اكثر من
سنه والامريكيون قالوا ثلاث سنوات في الحد
الادنى ا طيب اذا كنا نتحدث اذا عن
ضروره يعني انه هذه الضربات الجويه في
النهايه لن تحسم الامر هناك حاجه الى
عمليات بريه حتى الان التحالف الدولي يعني
يعتمد على اطراف اخرى بالوكاله للقيام
بهذه العمليه لكن هناك ايضا جانب سياسي
اشر اليه الان قبل قليل استاذ الياس حنا
ال الجانب السياسي هذا من يتولاه نتحدث عن
دوله اسلاميه يعني هذه الدوله لا تحمل
الملامح التقليديه للدوله نتحدث عن دوله
يعني شبحيه بين قوسين ليست دوله بمفهوم
الدوله في النهايه كيف سيكون الحسم هكذا
فقط
بض الضربات الجويه وضربات بريه
محدوده يعني انت ذكرتي نقطه مهمه للغايه
ان هذه ليست دوله وليست اسلاميه يعني هناك
نوع من بنيه تحتيه متواضعه للغايه هذا
التنظيم بدا بانشائها وخاصه في الرقه وبعض
المناطق العراقيه انا اعتقد النقطه
الرئيسيه في هذا يعني الجدال في هذا
المساله هي مساله سياسيه استرات
اجتماعيه لا يمكن هزيمه التنظيم لا جويا
ولا حتى بريا كف هذا التنظيم اللي بسموه
الحقيقه جز جزء منه ارد انسنس يعني معركه
في الداخل العراقي يعني ما لم يتم ردم
الفجوه الاجتماعيه السياسيه بين اطياف
المجتمع العراقي وهذا هذا ما تقوم فيه
الان الولايات المتحده وحلفائها اعاده
الحقيه استثمار في الشرائح العربيه السنيه
في العراق يعني الجيش العراقي وحده غير
يعني قادر على حسم المعركه ضد تنظيم
الحقيقه بدا يعني له حاضنه شعبيه وبكل
صراحه حاضنه شعبيه مهمه للغايه اللي كانت
في الموصل وتكريت وفلوج وكل المثلث الثني
اذا الوض العامل الاجتماعي السياسي هو
الذي يمكنه ان يحسم المعركه في تقصد
التعامل مع المظالم وانصاف الطوائف
المظلومه التي لديها مطالب سياسيه
واجتماعيه طبعا ومن هنا هذا كل الكلام عن
الاستراتيجيات كلام يعني على الهواء
النقطه الرئيسيه بالنسبه لحسم المعركه هي
الحقيقه سياسيا واجتماعيا من خلال الحقيقه
منع التنظيم من وجود حاضنه شعبيه له وخاصه
وهنا الحقيقه يا هل ترى هل لدى الحكومه
العراقيه هل لدى النخبه العراقيه هل لدى
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها يعني الرؤيه
والنضوج من اجل التعامل مع هذا مع هذا
الانشطار الاجتماعي في العراق النقطه
الاولى النقطه الاخيره بالنسبه لسوريا
الان سوريا الحقيقيه حرب اهليه طاحنه لا
الولايات المتحده ولا حلفائها يتعاملون مع
النظام السوري وطالما ان الوضع في سوريا
مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات لا اعتقد لا
التحالف ولا الجيش السوري الحر مع كل
احترامي بتواضع حتى الان او حتى بعد سنتين
يمكنه الحقيقه توجيه ضربه قاضيه الى
التنظيم ومن هنا هذه معركه مفتوحه ما لم
يتم يعني التعامل مع الجذور الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه لوجود هذا التنظيم الحاضنه
الشعبيه ووقف الحرا وضع يعني الحرائق التي
تشتعل في المشرق العربي وخاصه في سوريا
لانه لا يمكن فصل يعني المسرحين العراقي
عن السوري وطالما الحرب السوريه الحقيقيه
مشتعله انا اعتقد ان هذا التنظيم سوف يبقى
موجودا في سوريا لمده طويله يا للاسف شكرا
لك الدكتور فواز جرجس استاذ العلاقه
الدوليه ومدير مركز الشرق الاوسط في جامعه
لندن نشكر ايضا ضيفنا من بيروت العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه